Good morning, John, it's Pizzamas, everybody
that you know wants a piece of this, and if
you miss the fun, we're gonna have, I'll rub
your face in it.
Vlogbrothers videos every day, except for
weekends, 'cause we need a break, a mistake
that I made was doing this at all, because
Hank Green rapping is always, always, always
a bad idea.
Haven't I learned this by now?!
You know, John, I'm actually getting a little
worried that we're gonna acquire so many traditions
here on vlogbrothers, that eventually every
day will be prescribed.
It will have something from the history of
Nerdfighteria to do that day.
This is the Pisa John.
He's crooked.
I think all of our traditions and inside knowledge
are wonderful, but it can be intimidating
for people who are new.
Pizzamas is just a two week period where John
and I make videos every day, like we used
to back when we first started doing this in
2007.
Brotherhood 2.0 is what that was called.
I honestly don't even know where Pizzamas
came from.
I did a video last year on the history of
Pizza John, which is this shirt.
If you're confused about that, please watch
that video.
I worked hard on it and I think it's good.
Also, during Pizzamas, as you may have noticed,
we do Pizza Johns in various styles.
These are only available during Pizzamas,
they're for pre-order during this two week
period, and then they'll never happen again.
I don't even have any of mine, 'cause I tend
to give them away during the Project for Awesome,
which is another thing!
The Project for Awesome, if you are not aware,
is a thing that John and I have been doing
since 2007, since the very first year of vlogbrothers.
Basically, it's saying, hey, instead of uploading
whatever video you're gonna upload on this
day, instead, upload a video about a charity
that you like that you think does good work,
a little bit of promotion for that.
In addition to that, we also do a 48 hour
livestream, we have lots of guests and we
do lots of weird things and we have lots of
fun, lots of memes are created, new traditions,
it's great.
So the ways you can participate in the Project
for Awesome are: You can make a video promoting
a charity, you can donate money through the
Indiegogo campaign, which is a thing that
we will have for about a week, and a bunch
of cool stuff that you can get through that
campaign, we're getting stuff from YouTubers
and other internet people all over to donate.
You can watch the livestream, tell people
to come watch the livestream, watch Project
for Awesome videos, promote the just general
idea of the Project for Awesome, and you can
vote on the Project for Awesome videos that
you like the most.
During the first half of the Project for Awesome,
all the money raised is going to be split
between Save the Children and the UN High
Council on Refugees.
During the second half of the Project for
Awesome, the money is going to be distributed
to the charities featured in the videos that
get the most votes from the community.
So by voting, you get to influence where this
pot of money is going to go, and in the last
few years, it's been more than a million dollars.
Those videos, if you're gonna make one, are
gonna be uploaded at midnight on December
11th, that's right when it becomes December
11th.
I just spent all weekend watching the Extra
Life livestreams that the gaming community
on YouTube and Twitch do, and it's just got
me super jazzed for the Project for Awesome.
So if you want to make a Project for Awesome
video, start thinking about that now.
I will also link to a video where I explain
what I think makes a good Project for Awesome
video, if you wanna take some of that advice.
This one feels funny.
It's really soft on the inside, though.
Oh, and I should say, this one costs extra
and all of the proceeds from it will go to
the Point Foundation, which is an LGBTQ scholarship
fund.
John, I am excited to see you tomorrow, and
also on Thursday and then Monday, Wednesday,
and Friday of next week, it's PIZZAMAS, I'll
see you on Tuesday.
These shirts are, again, available on DFTBA.com
and will never be available again, they got
tear off tags so you don't have to worry about
the tags getting in your way, I love this,
it's also just satisfying.
I think this one is my favorite.
I don't know, it's just exceptionally funny
to me.
I wore it all day today.
Also during Pizzamas, we've got a Pizza John
ornament, a snapback, a window cling, some
stickers, and a travel mug, which, only available
now and then never again.
Never again.